[Musique]
londres 1982 monsieur alim tonnes est
plutôt pro europe au mois je suis
toujours pour le marché commun et madame
aline tonnes aimé plus de réserves
nous espérions beaucoup que la vie
s'améliorerait avec le marché commun
en fait c'est le contraire qui s'est
produit les à l'iden sont à l'image de
l'opinion britannique très divisé sur le
sujet européen et ce depuis que le
royaume uni a intégré la communauté en
1973 voilà ce qu'en disait alors un
groupe de jeunes il serait très
imprudent de ne pas prendre la chose tu
es entrée dans le marché commun et la
vie des plus anciens les anglais n'ont
pas des indépendances on aime penser soi
même créer soi-même sa façon de vivre en
1975 deux ans après l'adhésion
les travaillistes succède au
conservateur au pouvoir
à peine installé il organisera un
référendum 67% de la population vote en
faveur du maintien dans la communauté
européenne 32% contre la ville de
bradford a été le théâtre
d'affrontements
certes modérée entre partisans du oui et
du non en 1989 les élections européennes
n'intéressent pas la population le taux
de participation est de 38%
il ya un mille ici et à la manche et du
puissant à côté de l'ordre en 1991 ils
sont les seuls à refuser l'euro et la
suppression des frontières là c'est un
certain chauvinisme qui s'expriment
perdant plein peu notre identité nous
avons déjà changé nos poussées lauzon
pour des g et des mg et en 2012 ce n'est
pas en votre maison sondages quatre ans
avant le bras exit 56 % de l'opinion se
dit en faveur de la sortie de lugny
le roc en fait ça ne fonctionne pas nous
sommes les seuls à bien nous en sortir
soumis au référendum en 2016 le brésil
est votée à 51,9 pour cent et trois ans
plus tard en août 2019 selon un sondage
56% des britanniques étaient pour que
boris johnson réalise le break vite par
tous les moyens
[Musique]